what we're going to discuss in this
video is executive orders and these are
directives being issued by the president
of the united states that can have the
force of law and i know what you're
thinking
isn't congress our legislative body the
body that actually creates the laws and
isn't the job of the president to be the
head of the executive branch to execute
on those laws and if you are thinking
that you are correct but going all the
way back to george washington presidents
have issued executive orders some are
fairly lightweight they might be a
directive for something to be done in a
certain way or a small regulation or
even appointing someone to a job
but sometimes these executive orders can
be quite significant
and the constitutional justification for
these orders come mainly from two
different statements in article 2 of the
u.s constitution
in section 1 it starts off saying the
executive power shall be vested in a
president of the united states of
america
and at the end of section 3 it says that
the president shall take care that the
laws be faithfully executed and so the
clearest justification for an executive
order are times when a regulation is
needed or a directive is needed in order
to faithfully execute the laws but as we
will see
presidents throughout history have
really pushed the boundary here and have
definitely gone into territory that you
might expect to be the area of congress
now in terms of appreciating how
frequent these executive orders are here
is a chart that gives the average
executive orders per year for the last
few presidents and you can see at the
low end you have president obama and
president george w bush averaging about
35 or 36 executive orders per year and
then all the way at the high end you get
to gerald ford and jimmy carter now if
you were to go even further back in
history presidents like franklin
roosevelt had far more executive orders
than even this
and just to appreciate some of the most
significant executive orders ever made
lincoln's emancipation proclamation in
1863 which was delivered during the
civil war it freed nearly 3 million
slaves in the confederate states
in 1942 a few months after japan's
bombardment of pearl harbor franklin
roosevelt issues executive order 9066
which called for the internment of
americans of japanese ancestry
historians have really frowned on this
executive order because it was a blatant
disregard for the rights of these
americans but at the time franklin
roosevelt justified it as a national
security issue and then in 1952 during
the korean war steel workers are
threatening to go on strike and so
president truman issues executive order
340 that puts steel mills under the
control of the commerce secretary and
the justification here was that they
were in the middle of the war and that
steel is an essential material for
conducting the war
now what's really interesting about this
executive order is that the owners of
the steel mills did not like this and
they take the government to federal
court it eventually gets to the u.s
supreme court it's known as the case
youngstown sheet and tube company versus
sawyer where sawyer was the commerce
secretary
and the supreme court rules against
president truman saying that this
executive order went beyond the bounds
of even the president's implied powers
so the big picture here is that
executive orders are a method by which
presidents over time have been able to
expand their power beyond what is
explicitly listed in article two of the
constitution
now like in all things there is a check
on that power and much of that comes
from the supreme court's ability to rule
executive orders unconstitutional but
there still aren't clear boundaries on
what makes an executive order
constitutional or not and they are
likely to continue to be an area of
debate when it comes to powers of the
president